great friends I'm Alana and welcome to
my channel today I wanted to talk about
something that happened to me that I
guess is scary no matter who you are but
I feel it is extra scary if you are an
old public in the online community
because if people have heard of you more
than the average human people hate you
frankly if you exist people probably
hate you but basically being any kind of
public figure even on the tiny scale
that I am you're gonna find some people
who are just very mad about your
existence there are people who hate
Keanu Reeves I'm as shocked as you are I
don't think he's that good of an actor
but I definitely like the guy and now
someone's going to want to mow to me for
saying that I don't think he on a ranch
is that good of an act to see this is
how this works but basically some of my
information recently got leaked by III
actually the video game X book I applied
as media to be able to attend this year
and it turns out that their media list
was publicly available on their website
so virtually everyone who applied as
media which includes a lot of youtubers
and streamers as well had their
information go public it was a lot of
people a lot of people I know a lot of
personal friends thankfully I think only
one personal friend had the home address
leaked I did not put my home address
thankfully but before I changed my
details it was my phone number which now
naturally have changed and I've changed
every account that phone number was ever
associated with to be updated but I did
get like a lot of phone calls and a
bunch of texts my favorite text actually
from the whole thing was a guy who had
the audacity to use a Docs to ask me on
a date let me read this to you real
quick
it's some [ __ ] I know you probably find
this weird but I had a chance and wanted
to take it and it's not that different
to tweeting at you anyway so my name is
Brian I've always thought you were you
are incredible in pizza and don't does
that banning of the harassment you get
online Apple you're beautiful and smart
you know gaming really well and it is my
main passion in life too I live in LA as
well not close to your address but maybe
we can meet downtown for a drink
sometime I think you will be amazed by
what we have in common
I could roast him for that final comment
being amazed by what we have in common
but oh boy
using someone's uh phone number that you
did not get with that permission to ask
them on a date the balls on the guy
maybe I should go on a date with him man
I did also just get a lot of sex from
people being like hey you got ducks just
saying you know which I found very weird
like I would think it's common sense
that if that happens to someone you just
don't contact them you do not save their
number you don't do anything to people
who were like Heil on a big fan just
letting you know you got doxxed is like
I don't know that you care I think you
just wanted to know that I would see
something that you said to me it was a
mess
I also had people call me from Australia
which was obviously where my family is
from and I panicked about that a little
bit because I was like what if it's
Hospital what if it's a family member
whose number I don't have what if
something has happened to someone back
home and it turns out that was part of a
scheme where someone was planning to
call me and tell me that my mom had been
in a car accident and tried to get me to
go to Australia
thankfully I didn't answer any of them
or respond to a text or anything but
yeah I'm also had to change my email
address I had one guy be like hey Alan
I'm just wondering if you need a video
editor and I did reply to that one was
like dude I will never work with you if
you are approaching me by information
that you did not get from me it's super
invasive but I hope you haven't done
this to anyone else and then he was
apologetic and I think made up a story
about someone listing my email address
on a bunch of websites saying I was
advertising for video I didn't really
think he was lying because his first
email didn't indicate that he found any
kind of ad he was just asking casually
but basically it happened and yeah when
that happens it's scary especially
because from what we can tell the people
who found the docs are people who really
hate games media and I think the
scariest part of this whole thing now is
that a lot of games media probably feel
uncomfortable this is something I've
always like kind of tried to talk about
but it's very hard to articulate in a
small space of time or I'm just tweet
about it people have this perception
that games media will do whatever they
want to not make publishers angry that
you'll give a game on high school
because you want to keep a publisher
relationship yeah you gave one game a
law school because you want to please
the other publisher it's all [ __ ]
but the thing that I always want to
point out to those people who are often
very aggressive about that stage
is that actually in my experience with
almost a decade in games media I've been
more afraid of you than I have ever been
of publishers if I publish if I posted a
review on IGN and I gave a game that I
know people are excited about a low
score my head goes to oh [ __ ]
I'm going to be treated like [ __ ] on the
internet for the next week the comments
are gonna be awful they're gonna find
all of my social media and spam me with
abuse for a full week until they move on
which they always do so it's not that
big a deal I've always thought that way
before frankly instead of ever thinking
about a publisher my head does not go to
the publisher think it goes to oh [ __ ]
that's going to be an angry mob after me
for being honest and for the people who
talk about ethics and games journalism I
always just want them to think about
that you are scarier than publishes up
by a lot I don't think about what
publishers think at all frankly and if
you really want ethical games journalism
and honest reviews I probably wouldn't
abuse people when they give a game or
review score that you don't like because
you are scary that's not to say I've
ever change to school because of the
public which I totally haven't but when
I wrote my message and drama to preview
I remember walking out of seeing that
game early and thinking oh god it's bad
I don't like it the public is going to
kill me when I'm the first person to
tell them this because nobody seemed to
have any inkling it was bad before that
so I just wrote my preview very very
factually I did insult the game a little
I said that I thought the graphics
looked like The Sims 3 and not even The
Sims 4 which I understand is pretty
harsh but for the most part I just
listed facts and nothing else and if I
want so sad to be in tonight maybe I
would have been a little bit more
opinionated but I didn't want to deal
with the harassment back to the casing
point which is that yeah when your games
media people get very angry at you like
all the time like daily so having the
information linked to people who seemed
very excited about it being linked who
were talking about how we'd get what's
coming to us as games media was
definitely um slightly terrifying and I
think someone trying to manipulate me to
tell me that my mom had been in a car
accident there's all kinds of [ __ ] up
but I like to think that most games
media was smart enough to just ignore it
changed
details and everyone's fine but for me
honestly the thing that gets me about it
is that I've had such a bad year and a
half but there have been moments where
I've been super happy I've had highs but
if I were to tell you all of the things
that have gone wrong in my life in the
last year and a half I feel like you
would not believe me like the amount of
hits I have taken one after the other
oh it's been some [ __ ] but to wrap this
up and the actual purpose of why I'm
making this video is that I have been in
touch with lawyers kind of having
ongoing conversations about some
potential repercussions for the ESA and
for making sure about the people who've
dealt with this are safe and also just
mentally okay because of course that's
important to me and I know of at least
two other people are talking to separate
lawyers to try to see what the options
are and I guess to try to feel like
there's a sense of justice so I just
wanted to say I did tweet about this
before anyone who didn't see it if you
were tossed by the ESA by e3 please keep
a record of anything that happened to
you and if you get any letters or
someone shows up at your house or your
email phone number is used to be signed
up for something so you're getting a ton
of spam or it's making something
unusable please document all of that
stuff and if you have the ability to
please let me know I'm having ongoing
conversations with some of the people
who've had very harsh outcomes from this
and I've had pretty scary stuff happened
to them and I'm doing my best to put
them in touch with lawyers who can also
help with police departments in
different cities and can assist with
things like stalkers which is obviously
a big problem with that list too so
basically if you're on that list reach
out to me I am trying to help everyone
involved as much as I can which is
ultimately why I made this video but
then when I sat down to record I was
like there's a lot of interesting stuff
to actually talk about here the one
thing that really gets me about it
okay I swear I'll stop talking up to
this I don't have my microphone today so
my audio is probably not great and I'm
sorry is I feel like we're already
living in a cyberpunk future just
without the cool tech the James Charles
controversy earlier this year and really
got me on that James Charles is a
makeup.you chiba i think he was on with
the first male to be on the front of
covergirl magazine and there was some
controversy with him where another
youtuber like exposed him for things he
had done obviously in doing that by
using james child's name when he saw
when he was popular that other youtuber
got a bunch of exposure and subscribers
and views and then james chil had a
response that I felt was pretty
reasonable and he lost a bunch of
subscribers before this all happened and
then day in the back because the
controversy and the whole the whole time
none of that stuff is important to me
the thing that gets me about it is that
these are people attacking each other
virtually for fake currency that doesn't
really [ __ ] mean anything publicly
broadcasting a feud to deplete each
other's fake currency being subscribe
dazzle views to increase their own fake
currency and this is such a like a new
thing when it comes to the social media
age it's part of why cancel culture is
so prevalent why so many people the
minute someone does something wrong
they're not allowed to make a mistake
like a human you have to take them down
and kill them for that virtual currency
not that you even get me from canceled
culture it's just like just this digital
obsession with numbers that don't mean
anything
and I feel like the docs thing just
feels very similar aside from when it
comes to people's real world addresses
of course it's like information leaked
it's a literal data breach the people
who have that daughter now feel like
they have power because you can use that
data to affect so else's life and all of
it really so that you can tell other
people over the internet that you did
something but weird behaviors that have
emerged from the digital age and how we
already doing things and interacting
with each other like what [ __ ] robots
it's just I can't believe we got here
and I don't have any cool [ __ ] limbs
yet my kind of cut my legs off and get
like the feet like chill from Portal
what are they no fall boots I can't do
that yet but I could get cancelled
tomorrow because it's something that I
said four years ago that I don't even
necessary
really agree with now that at the time
might have been culturally relevant and
appropriate but everything you say in
the digital era is constant we've
literally removed the meaning of context
of history of time it's just
oh it's stressful really stressed me out
man you don't say have all that
corporate overload [ __ ] everyone
just kind of conveniently ignoring that
anyway this was a rant that I didn't
mean to get into I just feel very
passionately about the topic and finally
found a video where I could like squeeze
it in there somewhere but yes my purpose
was ultimately to tell people who have
been dosed on that list to reach out for
me I guess if you've been dosed in
general um feel free reach up to me
because I have made the contacts who
might be able to help you now and I
understand how scary it is and how
intimidating people can be with that
information
it sucks I'm sorry what happened to you
two alrighty everyone I am Alana thank
you guys for watching I don't know how
many people are gonna watch this video
it's very strange I will see you guys
next time bye